vamos a hacer un montón de ejemplos y
muchos de estos ejemplos tienen que ver
con crear una ecuación con los datos que
nos dan para así poder resolver este
problema y bueno con esto vamos a
resolver el primer problema que nos
dicen escribe una ecuación matemática
que describa la relación entre las
variables de la tabla y si te das cuenta
aquí tenemos el día y la ganancia por
día en el primer día ganamos 20 en el
segundo día ganamos 40 en el tercero 60
en el cuarto 80 y en el quinto 100 y
bueno si te das cuenta la ganancia va
aumentando de 20 en 20 20 40 60 80 es
decir que por cada día que pase vamos a
aumentar 20 nuestra ganancia más 20
nuestra ganancia y por lo tanto si
nosotros queremos escribir una ecuación
matemática que tenga que ver con la
ganancia y el día voy a poder decir que
la ganancia es igual a 20 por el día 20
por
el día y date cuenta que eso es
totalmente cierto si por ejemplo estamos
en el día 5 vamos a ganar 5 por 20 lo
cual es 100 entonces parece ser que esta
fórmula funciona bastante bien es una
expresión matemática pero si nosotros lo
quisiéramos tener mucho más mate
matizado podríamos decir que la ganancia
es que la ganancia es que el día es de
mh y entonces la ganancia es igual a 20
por d que es igual a 20 por 10 y
entonces ya tenemos aquí una ecuación
matemática que nos describe lo que está
sucediendo la tabla el inciso b nos
pregunta cuál es la ganancia en el día
10 entonces lo que hay que hacer es
sustituir el día por 10 porque estamos
en el día 10
entonces la ganancia en el día 10 quién
va a ser pues bueno ganancia es igual a
20 por el día pero estamos en el día 10
entonces voy a poner en lugar del día 10
y 20 por 10 es 200 por lo tanto en el
día 10 vamos a tener una ganancia de 200
muy bien ahora el problema 3 y dice
escribe una cuestión matemática para los
siguientes casos
así que vamos a hacer el inciso dice
siete veces un número es 35 cuál es ese
número y bueno cuando yo hablo de un
número puede hablar de cualquier
variable puede ser xy
sin embargo para hacerlo mucho más
habitual y para tomarnos la variable más
común voy a pensar en x cada vez que yo
vea un número voy a pensar en xy aquí
dice que 7 veces x 7 veces un número es
recuerda que ese es el signo de igual es
35 cuales es el número y bueno ya
tenemos esta ecuación o esta
representación matemática y aquí hay dos
formas de resolverlo la primera puede
ser dividiendo todo entre 7 si yo divido
ambas partes entre 7 voy a obtener el
resultado de x así que dividiendo entre
7 estos dos se van a ir 7 y 7 se van
esto pensando en el lado izquierdo de la
ecuación mientras que del otro lado me
queda 35 entre 7 por lo tanto la
respuesta de esto va a ser x igual a 35
entre 7 lo cual es 5 bueno esta es una
forma de resolver este problema por qué
podremos pensar en la siguiente forma de
resolver el mismo problema multiplicando
esta ecuación en ambas partes por un
séptimo es decir me quedaría un séptimo
por 7x es igual a 35 por un séptimo pero
de aquí llegaríamos justo a lo mismo
porque un séptimo por 7x me quedaría
solamente x mientras que del otro lado
me va a quedar 35 entre 7 lo cual es 5
así que vamos a hacer mejor el inciso b
dice un número es 25 veces más que dos
veces otro número y aquí ya estoy
metiendo dos números distintos así que
vamos a ponerles nombre voy a decir que
x es un número y ya es el otro número x
es un número que va a ser el otro número
y entonces ya con esta nueva anotación
vamos a tratar de escribir esta ecuación
dice un número es decir x es entonces
pongo el signo igual 25 veces más 25
veces más entonces 25 más que dos veces
otro número por lo tanto voy a poner dos
veces el otro número pero el otro número
se llamaba 10x es igual a 25 dos veces
y eso es lo que me dice la primera
ecuación y por otra parte me dice si
cada uno de estos números se multiplica
por 5 su suma es 350 esto quiere decir
que si multiplico a cada uno de estos
números por 5 es decir 5 x + 5 y porque
me voy a tomar su suma su suma debe de
ser 350 entonces esto tiene que ser
igual a 350 vamos a escribirlo con
matemáticas cinco veces un número más
cinco veces el otro número 5 x más 5 y
esto va a ser igual a 350 que es lo que
me tiene que dar la suma de estos dos
encuentra los números es decir lo que
necesito es el valor de x y el valor de
james y bueno me piden que encuentre los
números y ya tengo dos ecuaciones con
dos incógnitas pero en esta ecuación ya
tengo despejada x por lo tanto voy a
resolver este sistema de ecuaciones y
para resolver este sistema de ecuaciones
lo que voy a hacer es sustituir el valor
de x aquí adentro en esta otra ecuación
cada
y yo vea x en esta otra ecuación voy a
sustituir a esa misma x por 25 + 2 james
porque aquí me dice que x es exactamente
igual a 25 más 2 bien y entonces me
quedan 5 que multiplica x pero x es 25
más 210 perfecto 5 que multiplica a 25
más 2 james esto porque está
multiplicando x + 5 james es igual a 350
y date cuenta que aquí ya elimina la
equis lo único que me queda es una
ecuación que solamente depende de ella
así que distribuyendo me va a quedar 5 x
25 lo cual es 125 más 5 por 2 lo cual es
de gm más 5 y esto es igual a 350 y
ahora qué te parece si juntamos estos
dos de aquí perfecto 10 más 5 ya son 15
y muy bien y ahora tengo 125 más 15 y
esto es igual a 350 y de aquí como
podemos despejar alguien a lo primero
que se me ocurre es que podemos quitar
este 125
si yo restó 125 de ambos lados de la
ecuación
este lado de la izquierdo estos dos se
van y solamente me va a quedar que 15
james es igual a 350 menos 125 15 james
es igual a y 'cuentos 350 menos 125 esto
es 225 muy bien 15 y es igual a 225 y
justo en este momento ya tenemos una
ecuación muy parecido a la ecuación que
tengo aquí arriba voy a dividir todo
entre 15 y me va a quedar que el valor
de james es igual a 225 entre 15 pero
225 entre 15 es 15 por lo tanto ya
obtuve el valor del bien que vale 15 y
si sustituyó el valor de aquí voy a
obtener el valor de x como ye vale 15
entonces en lugar de llevo y escribir 15
me va a quedar 2 por 15 bueno 2 por 15
esto de aquí es 30 y 30 le voy a sumar
25 30 25 es 55 y ya tengo los dos
números el primer número un número equis
es igual a 55 mientras que el otro
número
james es igual a 15 así que déjame
borrar
esto para poder hacer el siguiente
problema el inciso c y el inciso se me
dice que la suma de dos enteros
consecutivos es 35 de que el número se
tratan así que voy a decir que x es el
primer entero de estos dos enteros
consecutivos y bueno si x es el primero
de ellos entonces como podemos nombrar
al otro de estos dos enteros bueno para
no ponerle otro nombre date cuenta que
el consecutivo de x es x + 1 por lo
tanto x + 1 es el segundo de estos
enteros consecutivos y dice que la suma
de x más el entero consecutivo que le
sigue x es decir x + 1 esto es igual a
35 y de aquí es muy fácil encontrar a x
porque x mas x
me da 2 x 1 esto es igual a 35 si de
aquí restó uno de ambos lados de la
ecuación voy a llegar a que 2x es igual
a 34 y ahora dividiendo todo entre 2 me
va a quedar que x es igual a 34 entre 2
lo cual es
17 x es igual a 17 x más uno es igual a
18 y la suma de estos dos me da 35 así
que ya está aquí tengo el inciso c y
vamos a resolver el inciso de que dice
pedro es tres veces más viejo que la
edad que tenía hace seis años cuántos
años tiene pedro así que voy a decir que
la edad que tiene pedro actualmente va a
ser p p es igual a tres veces más viejo
que la edad que tenía hace seis años por
lo tanto 3 va a multiplicar a la edad
que tenía pedro hace 6 años pero hace 6
años pedro tenía 6 años menos por lo
tanto a la edad que tiene actualmente
pedro le voy a quitar 6 años para que
así podamos representar la edad que
tenía pedro hace 6 años
entonces p es igual a 3 que multiplican
ap - 6 es decir la edad de pedro que
tenía hace 6 años y mira de aquí ya es
muy fácil despejar apem p es igual a 3
por ps3p y 3 por menos 6 esta humedad
menos
18 y de aquí voy a despejar a pepsi yo
restó 3 p de ambos lados de la ecuación
entonces del lado izquierdo me va a
quedar menos 2 p p menos 3 pm es lo
mismo que menos 2 p y del lado derecho
solamente me va a quedar menos 18 y
ahora si divido a ambos lados entre
menos 2 me va a quedar que penn es igual
a menos 18 entre menos 2 lo cual es 9
entonces pedro solamente tiene 9 años
está muy jovencito todavía ese pedro si
la edad de pedro actualmente son 9 años
entonces p menos 6 son tres años esto
quiere decir que pedro actualmente tiene
el triple de edad que tenía hace seis
años entonces si funciona perfecto me
agradó mucho este problema y vamos a
hacer el siguiente dice problema 6 un
reproductor mp3 de creció su precio un
20 por ciento del año pasado a este año
este año el precio del reproductor mp3
fue de 120 pesos cuál fue su precio el
año pasado entonces vamos a decir que p
es el precio que tuvo el mp3 el año
pasado y bueno para
sol ver este problema entonces quiero
ver cómo le quitamos al precio del año
pasado el 20 por ciento pero si te
creció en un 20% esto quiere decir que
al precio del año pasado le voy a quitar
punto 20 es decir menos 0.20 por p aquí
estoy representando el 20 por ciento del
precio del año pasado y le estoy
quitando esto al precio del año pasado y
esto dice que es igual a 120 pesos que
es lo que cuesta actualmente y ya está
una ecuación muy fácil de resolver
porque en 0.20 pm es lo mismo que 1 -
punto 20 lo cual es 0.8 0.80 p es decir
me estoy quedando solamente con el 80%
del valor del precio que tenía el
reproductor mp3 el año pasado y esto es
igual a 120 y ahora si yo divido de
ambos lados de la ecuación entre 0.8 voy
a dividir esto entre 0.8 o 0.80 y aquí
también entre 0.80 voy a obtener así el
valor de estos dos se van a cancelar y
solamente tengo que hacer 120 entre 0.8
vamos a recordar como hacíamos una
división con decimales 120 va a ser
dividido por 0.8 aquí va a poner un
punto y muchos ceros y hay que recorrer
el punto decimal te acuerdas entonces
vamos a recordar el punto decimal un
lugar un lugar hacia la derecha lo
recorro un lugar hacia la derecha aquí
lo voy a poner para que no se nos olvide
recuerda que es importante que los
lugares que recorramos el punto decimal
afuera de la división va a ser los
mismos lugares que recorramos adentro de
la división y me quedan 8 cabe una vez
en 12 1 por 8 8 y 12 8 es 4 bajo ahora
este 0 y 40 cabe cinco veces en 8
entonces 5 por 8 40 perfecto porque
estudias exacto
entonces menos 40 me queda 00 aquí voy a
poner un 0 y se siguen los ceros
entonces el precio que tiene reproductor
mp3 hace un año atrás era de 150 pesos y
lo padre de las matemáticas es que tú lo
puedes verificar si tú le quitas el 20%
a 150 pesos vamos a llegar a 120 pesos
eso es lo padre del álgebra que siempre
puedes verificar
tu resultado siempre puedes verificar
que esté bien tu trabajo